It is over 11.
you have freed me
you can't stop this now
Welcome back everyone this will be my
stranger things season 4 part 2 trailer
for the final episodes which are going to air
later this year there's a bunch of new footage
also explain everything that was going on with
the vechna in season four part one eleven getting
her powers back and what they were trying to set
up and what's going on with season five because
they did confirm that they are making season five
that'll be the final season if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and careful for spoilers from season 4
part 1 if you haven't seen those episodes yet
because we have to talk about everything that
happened all the big reveals in the trailer for
stranger things season 4 part 2 you have the voice
of the vecna the older version of henry creel
speaking to 11 from the upside down reaching out
to her telepathically through the gate saying
it's over you freed me you can't stop this now
and in a bunch of different places both in the
upside down hopper joyce and murray still in
russia 11 everyone all over the place fighting
the forces of the mind flayer in what the vector
henry creel number one is talking about during
that is that he's killed enough kids gained
enough power to weaken the barrier between
the upside down dimension in the real world
for all the other minions of the mind flare to
invade and try to conquer the regular dimension
we're talking armies of demogorgons demo dogs
the wing bats that we saw for the first time in
season four and the vecna himself just crossing
over into the barrier he's been free like he can
re-enter the normal world now there's enough gates
the reason vecna is telling 11 she can't stop him
now is just mostly more of him playing mind games
with her like trying to mess with her head but the
whole thing in season four is that dr owens and
dr brenner who's still alive surprise everything
they did during her storyline was to bring 11's
powers back and strengthen them like she's coming
back with a big upgrade the same way that vecna
just got a big upgrade after killing all the kids
when he's revealing his true backstory to both 11
and then to nancy in the upside down when she's
getting all those visions he reveals that each
time he killed someone it made him stronger but i
think what he's trying to say is that he learned
more about his ability the more people that he
killed it's not like he's sucking up extra power
it's the same thing with 11 like they were born as
powerful as they're ever going to become they
just didn't realize how powerful they were or
truly understand their ability until present day
that's why when dr brenner talks about bringing
11's powers back he's trying to fix her brain but
also they'll be even stronger when she comes back
because she'll understand more about how they
actually work also they want to tell you that
she's going to be as powerful as the vechna as
henry creel when he shows up and they actually
get into a fistfight like they'll have their
wizard battle but then they'll have an actual
physical battle too in the trailer there's footage
of them fighting the forces of the vector and the
mind flare in both the upside down like steve and
nancy look that they're trying to free robin from
the wall around them and it looks like they're
back in the upside down they were in the middle
of using the portal at eddie's house when the
vector killed chrissy but then something happened
to nancy when she was traveling through the vechna
somehow got into her head and was talking to her
revealing all these things about her backstory
so nancy was still trapped they had to free her
somehow that's probably why they wind up back in
the upside down separately you see more footage
of hopper murray and joyce back in russia it
seems like examining the other facility that the
russians were using the russian military studying
demogorgons that they captured this whole thing
with the facility the swirling black cloud is them
watching the remnants of the russian gate that
we saw during season three back in siberia when
the russians were trying to open their new gate
unsuccessfully or kind of successfully remember
hopper's group hasn't come back from russia yet
so all the stuff that's happening with him is
still happening inside russia but first things
first everyone asking about vecna's backstory
what does vegna have to do with the mind player
who is the ultimate big villain of stranger things
just in general like who is the real villain here
so henry creel number one vecna is not the
true main villain dustin aka dusty buns had
this line of dialogue in one of the earlier
episodes where he kind of explained the entire
hierarchy of power in stranger things and
it was meant as a throwaway line but it was
actually meant to be really important because
it tells you about who the real big bad is
wait wait wait what do we know that wants to
take over the world the mind player so if the
demogorgon was just his foot soldier that is
his five-star general dustin aka dusty buns as
i said earlier reveals that the mind flayer is the
true ultimate villain of the upside-down dimension
like the true ruler of this other red formless
space when henry creel enters it in the vechna
henry creel is just as general so during season
four it's using vechna number one to invade the
real world and conquer the normal dimension quick
backstory on the vector though the biggest thing
they reveal about him he is the former number one
the first test subject with powers that dr brenner
found and started experimenting on 27 years ago
in the late 50s henry creel was just this normal
child that discovered he had powers and eventually
went a little bit crazy killed his family also
driving his father victor creel insane putting him
in a mental institution that was the whole idea in
casting the actor who had formerly been known
as freddy krueger as his father because there's
a very freddy krueger vibe with the vechna very
dream warriors nightmare on elm street vibe but
then dr brenner gained control of the young henry
creel and tried to control him at first when he
found out that he couldn't he developed a special
program for little kids that 11 eventually became
part of when she was born later minting him as the
number one they never explained why henry creel 11
the other kids are all born with powers they might
wait till season five to do that it's still a huge
hanging plot thread either it's gonna be an x-men
thing where they're all just meant to be this
natural biological evolution of normal people or
something that the mind player did earlier in the
timeline often his dimension of the upside down
caused people to start developing powers in other
dimensions as he was beginning to invade them
either way so far on the show we've never seen
any other new kids younger than 11 show up with
powers after the events of season 1 when we also
learned that vecna henry krill when he was still
human killed all those other test subjects because
the people were developing powers naturally
just as this regular biological evolution
wouldn't there be other brand new kids popping
up all over the world in present day with powers
and we haven't seen that yet so it sounds like
something about these kids especially developing
powers might have something to do with the mind
flare itself so as dr brenner's program grew along
the years more kids like 11 showed up with powers
experiments continued henry creel naturally just
got older and older by the time 11 shows up in
the 1970s he's in his 30s and dr brenner is just
pretending that he's one of the other orderlies
helping manage the new kids when that happened as
part of this idea that he can't control number one
anymore he implanted this bomb inside his neck as
a fail-safe device but before he reveals the depth
of his craziness that he's really trying to take
over the world 11 still thinks that he's a good
person wants to help him and takes the bomb out
of his neck that's when he starts going around
killing everyone because they have no fail-safe
device against him 11 learns the truth about henry
creel defeats him but when she does she attacks
him with so much power that they make it seem
like she just disintegrates him into nothingness
but the force of her power that she uses on
him is so great that it rips a hole in space
and time across dimensions opening the original
hawkins gate from season one so the whole idea is
that right after this moment here she suffers all
this trauma and kind of blocks the memory of what
really happened in her mind but then the events
of the beginning of season one play out she uses
the card that henry creel had given to her to
escape the facility goes on the run they have
all the funny moments with the eggos hopper finds
her kind of adopts her she finds the other kids
becomes friends with them all the while forgetting
about what really happened with henry creel being
pushed into the upside down it's not till later
in the timeline during season one where dr brenner
is experimenting with the upside down trying to
enter and find out what's going on inside there
there's also this whole thing with the upside
down being frozen back in time just a couple
years frozen at the time period when she pushed
him in as if when she pushed him in and he became
the vegna time froze and then just continued on
in normal present day that's why nancy thinks
that they're stuck in the past when they're in the
upside down and in present day it's a couple years
in the future so what's happening here in this
final scene where you see what happens to henry
creel on the upside down is that when she pushed
him through dimensions opening that first gate
this is what the upside down looked like just
this formless mass of red energy and nothingness
this vast empty space so what's happening here
with him being hit with all the lightning and
being slowly transformed into the vector creature
is the mind flayer sensing him when he entered
and essentially taking him over twisting him to
his side and the mind flayer is what causes the
vechna to look like this with all the tendrils the
connections to the organic creatures in the upside
down henry creel isn't the person that did this
like this is what he actually looked like when
he went into the other dimension being hit by the
lightning strikes they just cinched him a little
bit burnt his hair off a little all these other
weird connections to all these other creatures in
the upside down are because of the mind player
the mind player is essentially using another
person with the same powers as 11 to conquer their
dimension using their own against them essentially
it's just busy trying to open portals all over
the planet so that when it invades it invades
all over the place not just inside hawkins hawkins
just happens to be a locust of a lot of its power
inside the real world so just to be clear henry
creel aka vegna is not the ultimate villain of
stranger things he's just like the next step up
on the food chain it's really all about the mind
flare and we saw a vision of that during season
two when it was watching them from the upside down
number one here is just its puppet so to speak
but when it comes to them defeating vecna they
set this whole running storyline with music
they made this whole big thing about how music
and people's songs are really important to
freeing them from the influence of the vechna
if you remember one of the earlier trailers
there's actually footage from the season 4
part 2 finale in that earlier trailer they just
didn't tell us it was from the final episodes
you see eddie's band playing heavy metal music
on top of his trailer in the upside down like
they used the gate inside his trailer to carry
all their gear into the upside down and they're
playing music to probably try and fight the forces
of the vechna they had this whole joke in previous
seasons about the never-ending story with dustin
and his girlfriend kind of singing that while they
were saving the world i think they're trying
to bring back around that kind of thing like
there'll be some kind of music that they will have
to sing to defeat the vegna in the season finale
that's why all the different characters were
talking about songs being very important when
talking about the vector i know there are a lot of
questions about the other storylines too like what
was going on with will's painting that he wanted
to give to mike this big secret painting that
they kept referencing in all the episodes but you
never saw previously on the show will had painted
things having to do with the mind player but he
kept having visions of it after they'd rescued
him they also teased this whole subplot where
they were trying to make it feel like he was
coming out so to speak to mike like his best
friend telling this big secret about himself
like the painting was meant to have this double
meaning that's why he didn't want 11 to see it
because he would tell his friends immediately
if it was just about the mind player like oh
we're in danger we need to stop this that's
why i think it also has something to do about
like some innate aspect of him coming out to
mike who's supposed to be like his best friend
but because most of his drawings do have something
to do with the mind player i think on top of all
the regular stuff that's going on inside his
head the painting will also have some clue about
the mind player heading into season five so big
reminder stranger things season five has already
been confirmed as the final season season
four part two the rest of the episodes are
just about them defeating the vechna and then
teasing whatever the final battle is going to
be against the mind flare itself there are only
two more episodes in season four part two like
there are only nine episodes total we just
got seven as the trailer says they're being
released july 1st supposedly they were also
shooting season five back to back with season
4 so they could get it out faster so i think the
idea is that they'll release season 5 episodes
around this time next year but if you have any
other questions about the other characters or
the storylines or what was going on during season
four or what's happening in the future just write
them below in the comments i just posted my brand
new mandalorian season 3 trailer video you can
click here to learn all about that and click
here for all my obi-wan kenobi episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!